hola miren es mi primo fall hola primo
cómo estás qué puedo hacer por ti hola
qué pasó nada estoy aquí haciendo vídeos
de khan academy bueno tal vez puedas
ayudarme estoy estudiando una colección
de figuras claro que necesitas mira las
figuras que están aquí no tengo idea de
cómo clasificarlas bueno hay muchas
maneras de clasificarlas una podría ser
por el número de lados que tiene cada
figura podemos pensar en el número de
lados de las figuras está bien y cómodo
eso bueno vamos a mirar cada una de
ellas y revisar cuántos lados tiene en
esta primera figura aquí tenemos un lado
esta línea recta que se encuentra entre
estos vértices es un lado dos lados tres
lados y cuatro lados entonces esta
figura que tenemos aquí es de cuatro
lados
y creo que ya entendí y esta figura
cuantos lados tiene esta figura bueno es
la misma idea podemos ver que tiene un
lado dos lados tres y cuatro cuatro
lados y está bueno este es algo especial
es muy interesante esta figura en
realidad no tiene vértices ni lados no
tiene bordes rectos esta figura es toda
curva así que no tiene lados ni vértices
y lo voy a escribir aquí arriba para que
lo entiendas bien ok si me gusta que
escriba es lo que realmente necesito ok
0 lados y 0 vértices y lo voy a hacer
para todas las figuras esta tiene cuatro
lados
cuatro lados y también podemos contar
cuatro vértices que son los puntos donde
dos lados se juntan aquí tenemos uno dos
tres y cuatro vértices
esta otra figura de aquí también tiene
cuatro lados ya los contamos antes y uno
dos tres y cuatro vértices así que
cuatro lados y cuatro vértices también
describe a esta figura azul esta ya
vimos que tiene cero lados y cero
vértices y la verde
esta figura verde tiene un lado dos
lados tres lados y cuatro lados y
también tiene uno dos tres y cuatro
vértices esta figura también tiene
cuatro lados y cuatro vértices que todas
las figuras tienen cuatro lados y cuatro
vértices no claro que no ya vimos que
esta de aquí tiene cero lados y cero
vértices y aquí tenemos otra que no
parece que tenga cuatro lados y cuatro
vértices no si los contamos tenemos un
lado
dos lados y tres lados así que esta
tiene tres lados
y contamos los vértices 1 2 y 3 vértices
tres vértices esta figura tiene tres
lados y tres vértices o muchas gracias
oye leí en una revista de figuras que
hay otras formas de clasificar las
figuras y hay una manera de clasificar
las figuras porque tienen los lados del
mismo tamaño dime cuál de estas figuras
tiene los lados del mismo tamaño ok
vamos a ver esto con calma si observamos
a esta figura nos damos cuenta de que
tiene cuatro lados pero este lado este
lado verde es claramente más pequeño que
este lado rosa así que en esta figura no
todos sus lados son del mismo tamaño los
lados no tienen la misma longitud pero
si observamos la figura que tenemos de
este lado vemos que este lado parece que
tiene la misma longitud que este lado y
también se ve como la longitud de este
lado y también parece que es igual a
esta longitud
entonces vemos que los cuatro lados de
esta figura tienen la misma longitud y
eso también es verdad para esta figura
verde que tenemos aquí la longitud de
este lado es igual a la longitud de este
otro lado también es igual a la longitud
de este lado y también es igual a esta
otra longitud y podemos ver lo mismo en
esta figura de tres lados este lado
tiene la misma longitud que este lado y
la misma longitud que este otro lana y
muchas gracias estoy listo para
clasificar mi colección de figuras esto
es impresionante ok me alegro de haber
podido ayudar